behold mortals Angemon
this is amazing
[Music]
I need this car in my life we're in
abu-dhabi realm of anthem on to ask one
of its creators turgid alpha god what
prompted him to build a real-life
transformer this woman gasps she
understood make oh my G lavish a
tarpaulin Mladic bee-boop in anonymous a
damaged immunity crisis emergency Jerry
on Nanda Devi cesky travel make tea baby
tuna Chocolat Martin heinzelman Dada
I'll give you Junsu trimmed amigos
pharmacology levels consider it shocked
turgid but how in the name of Optimus
Prime have they turned an everyday car
into an awesome but what's truly amazing
is that they've created this out of an
ordinary car
these guys have replaced most of the
mechanical parts with a complex
hydraulic system hydraulics work by
pumping a hydraulic fluid into a
cylinder which pushes on a piston and
amplifies the force hydraulic system is
comprised of three parts a hydraulic
pump that pumps this hydraulic fluid
around the system lines that move the
incompressible hydraulic fluids to the
end points and individual Pistons that
can move in and out with a great deal of
fish
the hydraulic system that antum on users
is huge and the power generated by
hydraulics is related to the size of the
piston with a larger diameter piston the
system produces more force the hydraulic
system to lift the car up is incredibly
powerful it can produce a force of
35,000 Newtons that's enough to lift
over three and a half tons finish
regardless to the mixture our arch
Foreman and robot for when I get I can
eat a shaman de Vere arlequin new web or
lick mark is in his aplomb masculine
ayatul driving message in Hutta Ecole
Koosh etiquette in yup of admission so
hydraulics help to transform and stay
stable but how is aunt amounts so
animated auntie mom's fingers wrists and
arms are remote control then they can
all be moved separately which means he
can wave at people and give a thumbs up
the head rotates back and forth the
operator can talk through the robot's
mouth the eyes can change to different
colors to indicate different emotions
and to top things off he's got a fog
machine which for some reason shoots out
between his legs but don't fear aunt
Aman is not taking over your city just
yet it can't walk if it needs to move
from place to place it has to transform
back into a car and drive to its
destination